[Music]
all right let's go to mark in milwaukee
what's up brother mark
good morning how are you
oh i'm doing real well how are you doing
this morning real well too that's great
what's up man
well
excuse me so
uh the situation that i have is
um
i have a family member that i'm really
close with
and at the same time
we can't have a face to face without
like screaming matches
and
a lot of that has to do with the fact
that in my perspective
he is just
an indescribable bigot
and i can't let it go
hmm
that's hard man
so
how do you hold in
two two different hands how do you hold
one he's a great man
and then the other hand
he's a bigot that is so hard to be
around i lose my character and temper
that's why i'm calling
[Laughter]
gotcha
um i think we all especially with people
we love especially people we respect or
people that we are in some sort of
forced community with
we often
have a picture of them that we make up
and we impose it on them
and then their reality
bangs up against that picture
and we
we end up being the ones that go crazy
and so i want to challenge your original
picture
that this person in your life is a good
person
or a great person
or a person worthy of one second of your
time
so give me some things that make this
character traits that make this person a
great person
very family oriented
extremely driven
loyal
loving
where he chooses to show it
um
it's very
he's giving
um
and i don't
part of it is you know obviously
the
the mental framework
and
values that i was raised with
so
that's got a lot to do with where it's
coming from in terms of my my respect
for the guy
um okay
so when the all the things you told me
there's a you can it has a fascinating
twist on them
driven loyal loving giving i wrote some
of these down
these are all traits that when you step
back and look at somebody
can point to a person of character
but it can also point to somebody who is
obsessed with control
oh
no comment
so when somebody uses love
as a weapon
it's this way and you get my love
it's not this way and i done with you or
i'm done with that group of people or
people who look like that or act like
that or love like whatever the thing is
um i will give
generously obnoxiously
only
if you're in my good graces and here's
how you get in my good graces
i will be loyal to the ends of the earth
for only my tribe with which i describe
the you know you see what i'm saying
these things can be really
i mean this is how i this is how i i
look at the people around me
like are people i associate with are
they generous in giving the friends that
i have when we go to dinner the fights
over who's paying not who's not paying i
remember back in college we almost came
to like fist fights over it i'm paying
this check for this table i'm paying
this check like it was a thing
and they're overly generous and i've got
friends who are overly loving
and overly like obnoxiously overly loyal
um
but it's a selfless type of love and
generosity not one that helps control
the world around them
right
so when you say uh like a major bigot
what does that mean
somehow
in every conversation racism gets thrown
in and it's just peppered in like it's
normal
and i just and and i i see white yeah
and i don't mean that in the racist way
i mean i was gonna say who's racist
just kidding
so yeah
i'm like whoa hit the brakes right here
right now i don't care what we're doing
i don't care where we are yeah i just i
just snap yeah and
this person is not going to not be in my
life so i need
tools or tricks and see i want to press
on that while that button down why have
you why have you trapped yourself number
one
on behalf of humanity thank you for
standing up and saying that's not okay
i'm grateful for that voice we need more
voices like that
okay thank you for that
um
why why have you locked yourself into i
will be in this person's life and this
person will be allowed into my life and
to my kid's life
um
well since i only called in to talk to
you about one topic
[Laughter]
i don't know if you ever listen to the
show it's never about one topic well
right yeah no but we don't want to peel
back that cover too far right now okay
um
he's in my nuclear family okay and
my nuclear family are
not the only people i can count on you
know like
underscored count on sure but
it's pretty much you know i don't have a
huge friend circle yep and
so it's
yeah
so let me let me
let's let's change this up a little bit
let's take racism out of here
all right
rage not anger but rage
kills us we know that
yes and so let's pretend that you have a
family member who's a great person
great guy
and every time you'll hang out he hands
you a cup of poison and says drink this
and when you do
you lose control of your body you lose a
couple of months off of your life
your blood pressure goes up
for the next 72 hours you can't think
clearly
you don't want to be around your other
loved
ones then you begin to doubt your own
sanity and your own
convictions about things because of what
they cost you
and that's it
guy's great nice kind he just has you
drink a cup of poison every week
how long do you begin to value your
mental health and your physical health
and your spiritual health
over
that
and when i say value how long to you
just say i gotta go make some friends
that don't ask me to drink poison
well when you put it that way exactly
exactly
ultimately mark this is
the value proposition here is you
you don't value you enough
because you've created a world where
this has to be acceptable
because i don't have these these other
things
and i want to tell you you can go get
those other things
you're worthy of
having boundaries where people aren't
disgusting
you're worthy of saying this is wrong
and this is where i draw this line
and you're also that means you're also
there's a reality to that
it's also worthy of going to
meet other guys meet other men and women
in your life that can come over that can
help you change the tire that can help
you fill in the blank fill in the blank
and
you're brave for making this call
there are millions of people going
through this right now whether it's
racism whether it's
any marginalized group coveted
conversations whatever it is
people think i have to take this dose of
poison
otherwise the rest of my life falls
apart and i challenge that
wholeheartedly
what i hear often is people say oh my
gosh i didn't realize that by holding
the line on this boundary
a
there was six other family members that
were like oh thank god now we can have
the conversation
or
i didn't realize how fun thanksgiving
could be i've hated it for 30 years
i didn't realize that it could be a
joyful holiday with just a couple of
knuckleheaded friends and strangers i
didn't even know we watched football and
played around and played domina i didn't
realize that there was this much
laughter that could be had
that's what i hear often
but to ultimately answer your question
you can't control his behavior you can
only control the boundaries you put up
and i want you to know you're worthy of
strong boundaries
do other people in your family not call
bullcrap on this
um
no well okay not the people that
i interact with there are some
there are a few others that i
think probably would but i don't
i don't uh spend time with them
so
just physical location etc yeah
i want you to have a life of peace
brother
well you and me both thank you well so
but the next part of that is this you're
choosing right now to not have a life of
peace
and i know that sounds awful and i just
put you in a corner but that's the
choice
and i know also know we could probably
there's probably more complex more
complexity to this story you know if you
and i were hanging out and you could be
like and this and this and this
um
but i want you to have peace in your
life brother and right now you're
choosing this relationship and this
toxicity and you're choosing just to
drink poison just so you can keep this
connection
it's why people stay in abusive
marriages it's why people stay in
keep going to the same christmas event
for 30 years in a row that's why people
stay in toxic jobs with bosses that beat
them up physically and spiritually
mentally
it's it's just look around at our
country man we're struggling
you're worthy of seeing i'm gonna be
around people who love not people who
hate